are you looking to land a job in tag but
want a mentor to guide you along the way
as many of you already know having a
mentor can be helpful when it comes to
navigating your Tech Career but how do
you find one and at what point do you
really need a mentor in this video I'm
going to be sharing with you three ways
you can find a mentor if you're looking
for a job in Tech and no these types of
messages are not going to work in 2023
make sure you stick around to the end
because I'll be sharing some messages
you can send to actually get a reply now
before you start finding a mentor you
might want to ask yourself these three
questions have I identified a specific
area or topic I need help on am I
willing to listen to other people's
advice and take action and do I want
ongoing support or just a one-off chat
with someone who can point me in the
right direction these questions will not
only help you figure out whether or not
you actually need a mentor but also what
type of mentorship might be right for
you in general what I've noticed is if
you're an absolute beginner to the tech
industry you probably don't need a
mentor to start with there are so many
beginner friendly videos and websites
that help you under understand what to
learn and what path to take but once
you've spent some time learning and have
a clearer idea of what it is you need
help with then it might be time to find
a mentor okay so the first way to find a
mentor is through a structured program
this is where you enroll in a paid
program that offers support for people
looking to learn a certain type of job
or work in a specific industry if you're
looking to become an engineer in one of
these companies you might want to check
out formation formation is today's video
sponsor and it was founded by top tier
Engineers from companies like meta and
Nextdoor who have interviewed thousands
of candidates and trained hundreds of
interviewers through the experience they
were able to create a more effective way
to prepare Engineers for the Fang level
hiring bar once you apply and get
accepted to the fellowship you'll get a
personalized training plan mentorship
from senior Engineers as well as access
to a network of engineering mentors
career coaches and alumni mentorship is
one of the most important components to
their Fellowship you'll get to interact
with senior engineering mentors every
week for code reviews small group
sessions and and mock interviews here
are some examples of what a typical week
could look like if you're enrolled in
their fellowship and you get
unconditional support all the way until
you have a sign off a letter in hand so
if that sounds like something you're
interested in make sure you check out
the link in the description below to
apply for their fellowship and even if
you don't get accepted into their
program they'll provide you with career
advice and a free interview prep guide
to help you with your Tech interviews
the second way you can find a mentor is
by reaching out to people on LinkedIn
this is something I did a lot of when I
was applying to jobs and I still have
two mentors I met through Linkedin that
I've regularly talked to LinkedIn reach
outs are great for one-off mentoring for
example if you're not too sure whether
to go into cloud or cyber security and
you want to get advice from someone
who's worked in both my usual
recommendation is to find a mentor
that's around one to two steps ahead of
you because they'll usually have the
most relevant knowledge and experience
to share as I've mentioned earlier you
need to be very clear on why you're
reaching out and what help you need
messages like hi I want to get into AWS
please guide me it's not going to get a
reply it really does help if you can
personalize your message a bit did the
person you're reaching out to attend the
same school as you do they have a
specific experience you find really
interesting if you invest time into
making your message more tailored and
more personal chances are people are
more inclined to respond to you here are
two examples of messages you can send to
someone to ask for a half an hour chat
now because you're asking for people to
help you for free this type of approach
is usually limited to a one-off call but
if the two of you had a good
conversation and you can sense that
they're willing to continue helping you
feel free to let them know you're
interested in an ongoing mentorship you
don't have to ask them directly will you
be my mentor just like how you wouldn't
ask someone will you be my friend after
the initial chat just express your
interest in continuing the conversation
and ask if they'll be open to meeting
again last year I had the opportunity to
Mentor over 250 people through
one-on-one career course but this year
I've decided to scale it down and only
have a few time starts open each month
if you'd like some help with learning
your Cloud role this year and wants a
one-on-one mentoring session with me
I'll leave a link down below to my
calendar page attending events and
meetups is also a great way to find
mentors in the tech industry rather than
having to deal with the potential
awkwardness of reaching out to people on
LinkedIn you can strike up a
conversation in a more natural way if
you're looking to land a job in the
cloud you can check to see if there are
any local meetup groups in your area for
example AWS currently has 478 user
groups around the world and Microsoft
and Google also have local communities
I'll leave links down below if you're
interested in attending an online or
in-person Meetup one bonus tip I have is
to try and use chat GPT as a way to help
you learn if you don't already know chat
GPT is an AI chatbot that can pretty
much answer any question you throw at it
people have been using it to write code
design websites and even as a personal
career Mentor okay let's give it a go so
I'm going to start by first asking
chatgpt to act as my career Mentor we're
going to start off with a broad question
and ask how do I become a cloud engineer
okay so they recommend first developing
a strong understanding of cloud Concepts
then gaining hands-on experience after
that building a portfolio networking
with others and finally looking for job
opportunities this is quite similar to
the advice I normally give when people
ask me the same question now let's say
you're having trouble with figuring out
which projects to build you can ask chat
GPT what are some AWS Cloud projects I
can build as a beginner and straight
away chat GPT shows you a list of five
projects you can work on it's important
to note that chatgpt does have its
limitations for example it's not able to
search the internet and bring you the
most up-to-date information but it's a
pretty powerful tool and if you'd like
to learn how you can use chat GPT to
learn cloud and other Technologies
please let me know in the comments below
alright if you found this video helpful
make sure you check out this video where
I talk about the top 5 cloud computing
careers for job Seekers